Here in the garden, let's play a game.
I'll show you how it's done.
Here in the garden, stand very still.
This will be so much fun.
And then she smiled, that's what I'm after.
A smile in her eyes, the sound of her laughter.
Happy to listen, happy to play, happily watching her drift.
Away.
Happily waiting, all on my own, under the endless sky.
Counting the seconds, standing alone, as thousands of years go by.
Happily wondering at night after night.
Is this how it works?
Am I doing it right?
Happy to listen, happy to stay, happily watching her drift.
Away.
You keep on turning pages, for people don't care, people don't care about you.
And still it takes you ages, to see that no one's there.
To see that no one's there.
Everyone's gone on without you.
Finally something, finally news, about the story ends.
She doesn't exist now, survived by her son, and all of her brand new friends.
Isn't that lovely?
Isn't that cool?
And isn't that cool?
And aren't I a fool to have happily listened, happy to stay, happily watching her drift.
Dream.
Away.